Let's look at the solution to our
performance versus number of cores quiz.
If chip power is 100 watts and
we can operate 1 core if that's the only
on on the chip at 5 GHz,
how many GHz do we get for 2 cores?
And the answer is that each of
the 2 cores now gets 50 watts.
That's half the power.
The frequency in that case is going to
be the cubic root of that one-half, or
0.8 times the original frequency,
so we get 4 GHz here.
The frequency with another doubling
of the number of cores is that each
gets half the power of these.
So it's going to be 0.8 times this,
which is going to be 3.2.
Or, we could do cubic root of
one-quarter of the original 5 GHz and
get the same answer here.
For execution time,
we need to account for
the change in frequency as well
as the change in parallelism.
So, this is what we get.
We get 100 seconds when we run all of
these pieces at just 1 core at 5 GHz.
If we ignore the frequency and have a 2
core chip, then what we get is that for
20% of the time,
we get a parallelism of only 1.
With 2 cores, for
the remaining 80% of the execution time,
we now have a speed up of 2.
So that time is cut in half, so
we get 0.6 times the original
time if we ignore the frequency.
So it will be 60 seconds without
the change in frequency.
Unfortunately, there is
a change in frequency.
60 seconds at 5 GHz, would translate so
we get 60 seconds x 5
billion cycles per second
is 75 seconds x 4 billion
cycles per second.
So the answer here is 75 seconds.
We would get 60 if we
operated at 5 gigahertz but
because we operate at 4, we need 75.
And then for a 4 core execution,
we get that out of the 100 seconds,
for 20 seconds we can't improve
by running on more cores.
For 30 seconds, we get the speed up
of 2 because we can use 2 cores.
For 40 seconds the speed up is 3,
because we can use 3 of the 4 cores.
And finally, for
10 seconds we get a speed up of 4.
Keep in mind that this is
without the change in frequency.
So what we get is 50.8 seconds.
Now we have to account for the change
in frequency from 5 GHz to 3.2 GHz.
Once we get the 50.8 seconds,
that's without the change in frequency,
and we get from 5 to 3.2.
When we compute the speed up relative
to this because of a lower frequency,
which is actually a slow down,
and we multiply that with this,
we get 79.4, which is actually
slower than a 2 core execution.
So as you can see,
although the 4 core execution gets
some more parallelism exploited,
it's not enough to make up for the loss
in performance due to frequency change.